toutes vos chansons sur les rassembler
en un livre
est-ce qu'elle serait un guide une leçon
d'amour oui ça peut appeler ça pourrait
fêter son but c'est vrai il y à tous les
stades tous les moments de la mort je
pense qu'il n'y a pas de recette pour
faire des chansons d'amour ce serait
trop facile mais pouvez vous me dire ce
qu'il faut qu'il y ait absolument dans
une chance en amour eh bien je crois
aussi bien
l'auteur que le compositeur doit être un
amoureux dans la vie sinon il ne peut
pas écrire des chansons d'amour
flotteurs sont amoureux mais vous
lorsque vous chantez chantez-vous mieux
lorsque vous êtes amoureuse
donc je suis toujours amoureuse je ne
connais pas de moments où je ne suis pas
une chanson doit exalté l'amour oui je
pensais quand on se moque de l'amour on
n'est pas grand chose dans la vie
ceux qui sont dégoûtés de l'amour parce
qu'ils ont eu des déceptions ce n'était
pas des vrais amoureux ne pas du moins
comparable à celle que peut apporter
l'amour
non je pense pas parce que même si on a
un travail à travail qui vous passionne
si on a personnelle qui la frayeur ce
travail je pense que il devient inutile
l'inde a pas sans l'autre jacques
prévert à parler du tendre et dangereux
visage de l'amour c'est comme ça que
vous le voyez je pense qu'il a tous les
visages plutôt tendre ou plutôt gras
plutôt dangereux tous les visages
ça dépend ça dépend du moment
dans votre répertoire de cette année il
y a huit chansons du même auteur charles
dumont compositeur même compositeur et
je ne sais pas si c'est une coïncidence
mais j'ai trouvé justement que vos
chansons cette année avait une autre
dimension quelque chose qu'elle n'avait
pas les années précédentes
oui c'est exact est quand charles dumont
ims évoqué remonte à porter la première
chanson non je ne regrette rien ça a été
comme une sorte de révélation moi c'est
à dire que j'ai senti qu'il fallait que
je fasse tout je recommence tout que je
me renouvelle tout à fait et
principalement dans la musique de
charles dumont j'ai trouvé ce que je
cherchais le le compositeur denis qui
m'aidaient carrément me à me renouveler
tout à fait et ce qui a aussi guidé mais
mes auteurs qui avait été créé avant
pour moi qui continue écrite et frime
michel bloch qui a collaboré aussi avec
charles du mot est bien décrire dans un
dans un sens nouveau
une direction nouvelle qui je prends me
convient beaucoup plus encore qu'avant